subaru share the love event made its
comeback this year giving back to local
organizations that do
so much for our community i was able to
help with the big reveal with the big
check reveal so take a look at this
[Music]
it is time to share the love once again
with findlay automotive group and subaru
of las vegas we have tyler quarter
here at findlay automotive group and now
you guys are no stranger to sharing the
love right
no this uh the subaru share the love
event fits
in perfectly with our findlay cares
program is supporting the local
community and local non-profits
today we have the children's discovery
museum and red rock search and rescue
and we're excited they both do great
things in the community so we're happy
to support them
awesome okay now i want to talk to
burton of subaru of las vegas because
this is your promise to share the love
right what does that mean for you guys
well you know this is our 13th year and
it is something that really warms our
hearts every year we get to do this
the middle of november to the first part
of january and a total of 300
for every car that was purchased or
leased was given
to a choice of a number of charities and
the customer got to make that choice
so for the discovery children's museum
are you ready you look very excited
we are we are gifting you twenty four
thousand six hundred and forty eight
dollars
[Applause]
is incredible oh look at the confetti
is this going to impact the museum this
is such a huge impact for us we're so
grateful to subaru for their partnership
burton
and tyler for just engaging us in this
process and all the buyers the car
buyers that have made this gift so
significant
so this funding will help us with our
steam education program in museum
and also with our outreach programs all
right so for our next recipient
introduce us okay
so we're supporting red rock search and
rescue we've supported them for a number
of years through the subaru share the
love
event and they do a great job in our
community helping us find missing loved
ones
and so it's a wonderful cause to support
they're just a great organization
whether they're up in the mountains lee
canyon or red rock or they're in the
city looking for
maybe an alzheimer patient that's
wandered off we just want to
to help these first responders and these
people that volunteer their time
to help our community and this is such a
joy okay are you ready for this donald
all right you are being rewarded thirty
five thousand
two hundred and thirty one dollars
congratulations
donald what does this mean to you oh
this means a lot red rock search and
rescue operates on 100
donations and subaru and finley
automotive group have been our key
supporter for many many years and we
really appreciate what they do for us
these funds all go directly to locate
missing hikers missing kids
alzheimer's kids with autism and also
our first aid and community training we
offer to the public so this is a really
big boost for us and we really
appreciate it
through our 2020 share the love event
recipients
the red rock search and rescue and the
discovery children's museum
and all of our community that came out
and purchased
subarus during that period we toast you
this year cheers to them we want to
thank findley automotive group for being
one of our community pride partners